I remember a time not so long ago when  they said unvaccinated people were evil  were killing grandmas we now have a  pandemic of the unvaccinated so you  could call unvaccinated people  terrorists just based off of some crazy  perspective you can speak out and  suddenly you're a threat to National  Security and then the government can  come in do whatever they want in the  name of National Security  um and in the name of terrorism wasn't  it um Justin Trudeau who called  unvaccinated truckers terrorists I think  he said it was a domestic terrorism I'm  pretty sure he said that using the word  terrorist is a bit like using the race  card the sexism card it's a way to shut  down a whole perspective